this video was brought to you by
curiosity stream and since you're the
one who screwed me I'd say you owe me
one
technically he screwed his wife hey
legal eagles it's time to think like a
lawyer you asked for it so more analysis
of suits today we are covering the
second episode in the first season I
think I will keep going with the first
season but if there are specific
episodes later on in the series that are
especially ripe for legal analysis
please let me know and maybe I'll jump
ahead as always of course please
subscribe and comment in the form of an
objection which I will either sustain or
overrule and of course stick around
until the end of this video where i give
suits episode 2 a grade for legal
realism so without further ado let's dig
in to the second episode of suits come
on you can keep abusing me No thank you
I'm done come on spot you three times
over Wyatt they're here you get set up
in the conference room yeah no I'll just
uh get set up in the conference room I
have never seen a law office that has a
game room like that even in New York
where losses for big firms can be pretty
nice they don't really look anything
like the kind of Silicon Valley startup
offices that you see often on TV so this
is not a particularly realistic
depiction of what a law firm looks like
what do you think you're going into the
room with the people wrong that's the
adult table in there and you haven't
earned the privilege yet I played air
hockey well you need to go back to the
office and file a patent for the phone
oh no fine let's figure it out can't we
do that after no so that would be crazy
to wait to file a patent for this
technology that you're trying to get
funding for effectively what's happening
here is that they're going to publish
the technology that they want these
people to invest in before they have
protected it we are only about a minute
and a half into this episode and this is
already malpractice that would probably
get these guys disbarred on top of that
this meeting is only gonna last a couple
of hours and it's always a good idea to
make sure your entire legal team is
up-to-date with all the information
that's going back and forth so if this
is a big in
deal Mike should be in there to learn
the facts on the ground and he should
have filed his patent months if not
years ahead of this meeting this is
crazy okay
have you ever filed a patent before I
just got back from this meeting with
Harvey and he wants me to file this
patent but I have no idea what that
paperwork looks like so have any help in
this Reno would be rude isn't Mike
supposed to be a genius of the law isn't
that why they hired him he's like the
greatest legal mind of his generation
even though he doesn't have a law degree
and yet he's constantly going back to
his paralegal for information about the
most basic things that lawyers do I I
sense some inconsistencies in this show
in the writing so far allow me to
introduce the Bainbridge briefs
wait wait are these Oh still printing
yeah I do about half hour
oh it's six printers 23 pages a minute
30 minutes that's 4,000 140 pages plus
all this which means the next I mean you
don't shoot a deal I would suggest to
make your back straight in reality if
you have gone to the printer with all of
your briefs all those briefs have been
proofed probably a dozen times by 10
different people in a big law firm like
this you would never go to the trouble
of printing out thousands and thousands
of pages of documents unless you were a
hundred percent certain that all of
those documents were ready to be filed
with the court but what is accurate here
and is kind of amusing is the way that
they bind all of these documents it's
called Velo binding it's those sort of
plastic jaws that you open up you have a
special machine that opens them up and
then you place the briefs in them and
then you close them up on top of them
that is for certain courts exactly how
you have to submit your briefs it's a
real pain in the butt so at least that
attention to detail is fairly accurate
please tell me that you filed a patent
no not yet give you to you yesterday
same time I gave you my Bainbridge
briefs which you haven't finished I was
here all night I barely got through half
and I was on hold for almost 11 minutes
before I gave up on your patent so
what's your point alright let's talk a
little bit about what it means to file a
patent the paperwork to file a patent is
not particularly complex there are forms
that you can use it's not that hard the
problem is that filing for a patent is
not just filing for a patent it's all
the work that goes into filing for the
patent before you do it if there is
prior art meaning that there is someone
who filed a similar patent before yours
or that your idea has already been taken
somewhere else then your patent will be
invalid so when you go to a law firm and
ask that they file a patent on your
behalf you're not just asking for them
to file the actual physical paperwork
for the patent what you're asking them
to do is hundreds of hours of work where
attorneys will cull through the database
that contains all of the other prior
applications some of which have been
denied some of which have been approved
and they're looking for similar things
that might invalidate your own pen and
in fact if you're following politics you
might know that our acting Attorney
General Matt Whittaker was involved with
a company called worldwide marketing
which was an infamous patent scam that
was known for filing patents without
doing the legwork to find out if there
was prior art so a lot of people who
paid tens of thousands of dollars to
this company in order to get patents
approved found that their patents were
actually invalidated because this
company wasn't doing a prior art search
so it's crazy number one that they
haven't filed a patent for this thing
before they've gone to investors and
number two it's crazy that they think
it's just a simple matter of filing for
the patent itself when in fact it's the
hundreds if not thousands of hours it
takes for the legwork before you file
for that patent wanna see me
so
I look for your work on the Bainbridge
briefs
it's spectacular it's just proofing
how can proofing something being
spectacular top it just heard from Wyatt
you got a response from the Patent
Office you got a response back from the
Patent Office a day after you filed your
patent that that does not happen and
it's been denied what evidently there
was a similar claim what do you mean
somebody beat us to it
No someone beat you to it they filed
less than 24 hours ago which means you
filed a day later than you said you
would oh my god well yeah that's why you
file for a patent months if not years
before you start getting investments
from outside people that's the problem
with going to investors before you've
gotten the patent this whole episode is
so stupid what's gonna happen now
I suggest you get on the phone call a
patent office and find out who beat us
to it then you're gonna have Donna find
any judge who will listen so we can get
an injunction and stop whoever it is
from launching their product first okay
an injunction on what grounds it's true
that sometimes you can seek it the
extraordinary relief from a court an
injunction which is basically a court
order that prevents someone from doing
something or it forces them to do
something but you have to have legal
grounds to do it and the fact that
someone filed a patent based on the
information you provided to them is not
grounds for an injunction unless there
was some sort of non-disclosure
agreement at the investors meeting but
that seems relatively unlikely we'll see
not a good legal tactic so far hey
Harvey did you tell him it was me
why would I do that I'm responsible for
you it was me yeah and that would be
true whether Mike was actually an
attorney or not which he is not in this
case Harvey is the lead attorney he's
the one that's signing the papers most
likely and so it's his neck on the line
also by the way it was his decision not
to file for a patent until after he met
with investors that is malpractice he'd
get totally disbarred for that did you
not see the sign outside just putting it
away Your Honor it should already be in
your pocket but you were running late so
perhaps that's why was it let the record
show the counsel is fined $1,000 for
failing to follow the posted rules of
the court your honor I do mouthing off
well be gone yeah so that's a bit
extreme but I have seen judges throw
attorneys out of their courtroom for
cellphones whose ringers go off I've
never seen a judge chastised counsel for
just displaying a cellphone that's not
making any noise but if the rules of the
court say that you can't have a
cellphone in that courtroom then you
can't have a cellphone in that courtroom
the judge gets to decide what goes on in
his or her court and there are plenty of
courts that don't even let you take a
cell phone into the building itself that
is the case with a lot of the federal
courthouses in Virginia and Washington
DC where I practice so you really have
to be careful and know the rules of the
court before you head into the
courthouse requests tonight court
adjourned
good morning better luck next time
Harvey
now I want him when I go against you
[Laughter]
your honor
send them in oh no no no no you do not
get to have a private meeting with the
judge without opposing counsel present
this is an ex parte communication
this is totally improper even though the
judge has already denied this request
there might be an appeal there might be
other issues in this particular case
this is totally improper to meet with
one side and not the other this should
never happen I could have you brought up
a review for talking to me like that
then we can get it all on record get
what whatever it is that you seem to
have against me for no apparent reason I
have a solid argument for any reasonable
judge to grant my injunction so solid it
begs the question why do you have it in
for me and I don't even know your first
name
really my wife never mentioned it your
wife the woman you had an affair with
last month okay so that is what we call
a classic conflict of interest in
California what you would do is file a
one seventy point six which is a request
for the judge to recuse themselves there
is no possible way that this judge gets
to preside over this particular case
when he has a huge bias problem now that
Harvey knows this information he
absolutely should bring this judge up on
review the damage has already been done
though the judge has issued his ruling
so he can't back out now
there is not going to be a good outcome
for this judge regardless of what
unscrupulous conduct Harvey has engaged
in here this is not good
thank god he's terrible at tennis
[Music]
both terrible atenas my earlier ruling
wasn't clear enough for you crystal but
I didn't want you to suffer for it
you see if you don't sign my injunction
there's gonna be a lawsuit and when the
next judge sees all the facts he's gonna
overturn your ruling you may be right oh
well by then your clients will have
dumped you you may be right but that's
sterling reputation that you value so
highly down the tubes
oh boy okay so this is called blackmail
this is incredibly unethical not to
mention this is yet another ex parte
communication which is totally improper
man I mean at this point Harvey's gonna
get disbarred the judge might be
disbarred and removed from the bench of
this ever it comes to light this is
violating your oath as an attorney you
filed for divorce soon enough perhaps we
could discuss a little quid pro quo
before I do I'm listening
you signed a document that says you've
slept with my wife I'll give you your
injunction and why would you want me to
do that to prevent her from taking me
for half of everything I own so what
you're saying is you'd like to blackmail
me I'm saying we could both benefit
you're blackmailing each other he just
came in there and tried to blackmail the
judge into giving him a verdict that he
wanted and now the judge is trying to
blackmail him right back I mean these
two deserve each other
and since you're the one who screwed me
I'd say you won't meet one technically
he screwed his wife did the snapping
thing and Gregory's me
you're high
get out oh that is not a good sign
look this is not my fault all right
Lewis made me do it Louis did right he
put a gun to your head made you smile
yeah he did he pulled out the drug test
which I failed by the way and then he
told me that if I didn't smoke pot to
help him land this new client that he'd
fire me it's not so different than
asking someone out for drinks is it you
and I had a deal
I'm sorry and if next time Lewis asks
you to do something that I told you not
to do what then I told you that I did
not have a choice oh because he had a
gun dear yes and what are your choices
if someone puts a gun to your head are
you talking about you do what they say
or they shoot you wrong you take the gun
you pull out a bigger one or you call
their bluff or you do any one of a
hundred and forty-six other things this
is a really interesting situation I
think that Louis might be liable for
conspiracy to engage in illegal drug
consumption obviously Mike is guilty of
having consumed an illicit substance in
New York it's still illegal to consume
marijuana but he was induced to do so by
Louis they engaged in an agreement for
him to engage in this particular action
for the gain of both of those
individuals so I think that given that
there is an agreement there is an overt
act to further the ends of the
conspiracy here I think Louis may in
fact also be guilty of the object of the
conspiracy itself so Louis is as
culpable as Mike for engaging in smoking
marijuana interesting legal situation do
you know how long it was before I got to
sit at the adult table he was when I
brought in my first client which I don't
recall you having done it and when you
screwed up that patent and why it went
apeshit on me I didn't put that on you I
took it on myself I mean you both
royally screwed up that time that's not
just Mike Louis told me what you did at
the club I bet he didn't tell you the
whole story
told me enough to impress me she landed
the client new business is hard people
will promise you the world but until
they sign that engagement letter means
nothing I don't know what you told Tom
Keller but bring a client in at your age
that reminds me of Harvey that's true it
is very unusual for junior associates to
bring in new clients especially
potentially a summer associate like Mike
it's unclear to me whether he's a summer
associate or a junior associate he was
interviewed as a summer associate which
is like an internship but he is acting
like a junior associate writers didn't
quite get that one right at any rate it
is incredibly unusual for a first-year
junior associate to bring in a client of
any kind and that is the way that you
get promoted you know almost immediately
what are you showing us this is a
website available at the Sun Tech domain
name all the design plans and
calculations have been uploaded is this
online now can be which means the whole
world will have access to my design
there'll be 10 knockoffs of that foam
before you can catch a cab back to your
headquarters we could file an injunction
not before tomorrow and once that
technology is out there good luck
putting that genie back in the bottle
well then we'll sue but my client won't
have any money what do you will have is
credit for the initial design which
after incorporates under a different
name will be worth a hell of a lot more
money than the 20 million dollars a year
offering yeah except that if the other
side's patent is valid then they can sue
anyone who uses those designs and builds
the prototype without their permission
that's the point of the patent
protection and they would probably be
able to sue this poor gentleman out of
existence for a whole raft of things
including intentional interference with
contract disclosure of trade secrets and
still at the end of the day these
nefarious guys on the other side still
have their patent because Harvey and
Mike didn't file their patent when they
should have so yeah this is probably yet
another malpractice in disbarment trap
what is this the copy of the Judicial
Conduct codes
friend of mine works at the attorney
general's office it gave it to me we had
a nice kind of value I told him if you
were willing to blackmail someone once
chances are you've done it before he's
very anxious to meet you
you think you can get away with screwing
my wife and then have me investigated
you actually have it the wrong way
around the only thing I've done so far
was have you investigated what I never
actually slept with Lauren but I knew
you'd never believe me so I kept my
mouth shut but now that she's getting a
divorce my policy no longer applies and
of course she's free to date but whoever
she pleases and she pleases me enjoy
your evening Donald no honor among
thieves the judge should have gotten him
to sign an affidavit at the same time
that he issued his ruling if he really
was gonna follow through with the
blackmail here that was just poor
loitering on the judges part all right
so now it's time to give suits episode
two a grade for legal realism there was
some accurate discussion of what it
takes to file for a patent but also a
complete disregard for all of the
legwork that goes into it and of course
all of the attorneys in this episode
would have been disbarred many many
times over last time around I gave suits
a b-minus
I'm afraid this episode is slightly less
realistic so I'm going to have to
downgrade it to a c-plus suits is not
exactly the most realistic show out
there Harvey and Mike seem to know
nothing about the law but if you're
looking for the best documentaries and
nonfiction movies that exist you need to
check out curiosity stream for example
I'm watching David Starkey's documentary
on the Magna Carta which explains how
the 1215 Charter made everyone's subject
to the rule of law and became the
foundation of the US Constitution it's
the same rule of law that Mike and
Harvey disregard every single episode
legal eagles get a free account for 30
days by clicking the link below or using
the promo code legal eagle so a few days
on curiosity stream and you'll know more
about the law than Harvey and Mike put
together so check out the link below
start learning about the
world not the fictional world of suits
and until next time I'll see you in
court